[Música]
llegamos al gigante asiático donde hoy
inicio en la cumbre de los jefes de
estado de brasil y rusia india china y
sudáfrica brics donde se enfocarán en
potenciar el multilateralismo y
desarrollo global también la
transferencia de tecnología cooperación
sanitaria reducción de la pobreza
armonía con el medio ambiente y la
articulación de la economía financiera
capaz de superar la actual crisis
mundial
todo esto quieren orar estos líderes
para ello entonces quiero saludar a
nuestro corresponsal en beijing adrián
foncillas a adriana muy buena noche es
esta una oportunidad para putin de
superar el aislamiento
internacional debido a esta guerra
si putin podrá significar que no está
solo pero creo que en cualquier caso
deberíamos matizar ese aislamiento que
repetimos y que deriva de cierto
ombliguismo rusia ha sido aislada por
occidente es cierto presidente sólo
supone el 17 por ciento de la población
mundial y los brics son un ejemplo
ninguno de los países ha secundado las
sanciones y sólo 1 brasil firmó la
condena de la onu pero aclarando
inmediato que su postura era neutral así
que la cumbre será una extraordinaria
campaña de relaciones públicas para
putin que podrá vender a su audiencia
interna y además le permitirá acelerar
la renovación de su cartera de clientes
putin ya dijo ayer que enviará hacia los
brics las exportaciones energéticas que
hasta ahora iban a europa y también para
chinas era una oportunidad de mostrar
cierto liderazgo global justo en las
vísperas de las reuniones del g7 y de la
otan y en las que se espera que suba la
hostilidad hacia pekín
también le quiero preguntar adrián de
los objetivos y ha cumplido el bloque de
los brics desde su fundación y qué retos
además se plantean
bueno el grupo nació en 2009 para
combatir lo que era una injusticia
flagrante y es que china brasil india y
rusia y unos años después sudáfrica
estaban
infrarrepresentados en la estructura
financia área financiera actual diseñada
por occidente después de la segunda
guerra mundial principalmente el banco
mundial y el fondo monetario
internacional y eso a pesar de que los
brics ya suponen el 40 por ciento de la
población y el 25 por ciento del pib
mundial pretendían crear un orden
financiero paralelo más comprensivo con
el mundo en desarrollo y si tenemos que
juzgarlo por esas expectativas es
obligatorio concluir que ha fracasado
primero porque occidente mantiene firme
el timón y segundo por las diferencias
entre sus miembros especialmente entre
china e india- que acumulan décadas de
desconfianza por conflictos fronterizos
y esas diferencias afectan aún al
funcionamiento del grupo por ejemplo
china quiere ampliarlo para anotarlo de
más poder pero hoy en día se opone
porque teme que los nuevos miembros
estarían bajo la órbita de china también
es muy probable que india en esta cumbre
vaya a impedir
beligerantes declaraciones contra la
otan y el extensión y el expansionismo
de eeuu que han salido de cualquier
reunión entre china y rúsia de los
últimos meses